my name is Colleen English I'm the
superintendent for sustainable
development communities and external
relations with Diavik online there's a
couple of different things that are
being done around closure what one of
the strongest so again a fairly legged
negative legacy in the North around
minds and especially closing minds
leaving sort of environmental disasters
and those types of things behind and so
that was another big component of our
environmental assessment was let's start
talking about closure now let's start
planning for closure now while you're
developing the line and so a lot of the
design of the mind was actually geared
towards closure there's a couple of key
components we have an interim closure
and reclamation plan that we've always
had we started with a closure plan will
end with the closure plan essentially
but that plan is going to evolve and
change as our mind progresses that plan
is definitely going to evolve and change
and so we just went through our last
submission our most recent submission of
the interim closure reclamation plan
which was approved by the kizi land and
water board and that basically says you
know for this point in the mine life
this is what we have planned but we
still have these questions that we need
to answer in order to know fully how
this mine is going to look when it's
closed a lot of those questions come
back to community concerns and and
really just trying to work with the
communities to say what does this
landscape look like when we're gone you
know what are that what are some of
those key components for the environment
that are going to that are going to link
into how wildlife uses the area you know
what the what the landscape looks like
in general so if you talk about a rock
pile you know is it smooth and round so
that caribou can come up it and over it
or do you keep it blocky and steep so
that they don't go near it you know what
are those kind of considerations that
the communities have that they want to
see in the end when the mine is closed
so that interim closure and reclamation
plan will eventually lead to a final
closure plan and and that's something
that we're really starting to generate
discussions on with the communities
now to try to start them thinking down
the track of you know what do you want
the mind to look like in me and what's
that landscape going to look like for
you who might want to go back and use it
well after the mine is done right now
when you look at that picture of your
mind you you know one of the problem
most prominent features of it is this
open pit what's gonna happen was that
yeah so the plan is that the pits would
be filled with water once it's done so
one of the things that's been talked
about is sort of washing the walls of
any of the residues that may be on the
on the pit walls that's been something
that's been raised by the communities
and then the pits would be filled with
water so we would pump water in to the
pits the water would sit within those
pits in order for us to be confident
that the water quality is good enough to
be linked back into lac de Gras and then
the plan is to breach the dikes of the
pit so basically to cut out sections of
the dike so that then this whole area
would be reconnected back to left to
grow as it was before so obviously that
was sort of underwater before and it
would be under water again at closure
and then chunks of the island would be
left as islands as we're there before
and then some of this area here is
actually fish habitat being designed so
man-made fish habitat essentially that
that will be left as shallower areas
that fish can use for spawning so that's
the plan